احتياجات الاقليه الصربيه في شمال كوسوفو
مستمره طالب المحتجون الذين تجمعوا في
محيط مقر بلديات الشان
بسحب قوات الشرطه وعدم دخول رؤساء
البلديات المنتخبين اخيرا قالوا انهم
مسالمون ويريدون الحريه ويصفون رؤساء
البلديات اولئك بانهم مزيفون وتواجه
السلطات الكوسوفو ضغوطا لتنظيم انتخابات
جديده في تلك البلديات بمشاركه الصرب وفي
تصريحات خاصه للجزيره جدد الممثل الخاص
للاتحاد الاوروبي للحوار بين بيل جراد
وبريتشناف لاجاك تلك الدعوه واعتبر ان
فيها حل الوضع المتازم وان تطبيع العلاقات
بين بيل جراد
لا يمكن ان يتم دون ذلك
نعرف ان الصرب في كوسوف قطع الانتخابات
الماضيه وهم يمثلون اكثر من 90% في تلك
المناطق فهي من الناحيه القانونيه السليمه
لكنها من الناحيه السياسيه تفتقر الى
الشرعيه لذا يجب ان تكون هناك انتخابات
جديده بمشاركه صرب كوسوفو وسيساهم ذلك في
حل الوضع وخفض التوتر الحاصل الان
لكن قاده الكوسوفو يعتبرون ان التهديد
الحقيقي ياتي من صربيا التي يقولون انها
تنكر في الاصل وجود دوله كوسوفو وحمل رئيس
الوزراء البين كورتي بيل جراد مسؤوليه
الاضطرابات الراهنه ودعا خلال حديث
للبرلمان قائمه الصرب كوسوفو لتحمل نتائج
قرارهم بمقاطعه الانتخابات الاخيره
من هم في السلطه في بلغراد هم الذين
ينظمون هذه الاحتجاجات ما يعني انها ليست
احتجاجات حقيقيه انها لا تعكس اراده الشعب
الخطا الاساسي لقائمه حزب صربكوسوفو هو
مقاطعتها للانتخابات ولا ينبغي ان تدفع
ثمنه جمهوريتنا انه قرارهم السياسي ويجب
عليهم مواجهه العواقب غالبيه سكان كوسوفو
البالغ عددهم نحو مليوني شخص من الالبان
المسلمين بينما يقطن نحو 120 الف من الصرب
الارثوذكس في الشمال على حدود صربيا تتركز
الاضطرابات الحاليه في ثلاث بلديات شماليه
هي ليبو
سافيتشان وزوفين
جرت في هذه البلديات انتخابات في ابريل
الماضي نظمتها حكومه كوسوفو وشارك فيها
الف وخمسمائه ناخب فقط من اجمالي 45 الفا
مسجلين بعدما قاطعها جميع الصرب
ويذكر التوتر المتصاعد ولو من بعيد بالحرب
التي شهدتها كوسوفو عامي 98
وتسعه وتسعين من القرن الماضي والتي اودت
بحياه اكثر من عشره الاف شخص وشردت اكثر
من مليون اخرين